as we all know julie has not appeared on
the talk since we premiered last Monday
moments ago she recorded a message for
everyone from the set of Big Brother
where she's working on tomorrow night's
show we are all about to hear this
message for the first time I stole it I
have been at the talk since the day it
started nine years ago and the cast crew
and staff have become family to me over
the years but right now I need to spend
more time at home with my husband and
our young son so I've decided to leave
the talk I want to thank everyone at the
show for the wonderful years together I
will always always cherish the memories
we shared most important I want to thank
you the viewers for allowing me into
your home every day it was a privilege
that I will forever be grateful for to
everyone behind the scenes I send you my
love I will miss you all very very much
- Eve you're the newest one at the table
but I feel like I've known you forever
you are even more beautiful inside than
you are on the outside if that's even
possible because you know I think you
are flawless Cheryl thank you for being
the perfect go-to partner for the last
seven years I open you close and you
always bring down the house we called
ourselves the bookends remember and we
always laughed when we said it to each
other your wit and timing and humor and
compassion and intelligence is simply
unparalleled you are incredible
cariann I don't know but in my opinion
you look awful good sitting in that
chair my Asian sister I'm just saying
and finally to Sarah and Sharon we've
been together since day one at the talk
I've spent every day with you both I
will always treasure our friendship the
great parenting advice from both of you
and the memories that laughs and all the
private jokes that the three of us have
shared we are the original Three
Musketeers I love you all and I know
this show
and The Sisterhood it stands for will
live on for many many many more years to
come
you ladies got this and I cannot be more
proud to call you my friends I love you
[Applause]
first of all thank you so much Julie for
the kind words I created this show as a
place for friends to come together and I
know I speak for all the hosts when I
say we thank you for eight years of dear
friendship and for all that you did to
contribute to the success of this show
we love you Julie and to all of you
thank you and we'll see you tomorrow
you
[Music]